[Music]
i hope we do
like
oh
oh my god
oh no
just flicks her aside
you would be wise to surrender
yeah
probably
cow cow
cow welcome back to new rock stars the
obi-wan kenobi series we'll explore the
most dangerous era in star wars history
for a jedi when darth vader and the
inquisitors hunted them down with
merciless zeal the same era of the
amazing game jedi fallen order and after
nods to that game from the recent bd
droid of boba fett in the setting of the
fortress inquisitorius on nerd in the
upcoming obi-wan kenobi series as well
as the recent appearance by actor
cameron monaghan at disney's galaxy's
edge is this all pointing to calcus
making a cameo in
forgive me for not committing to the
full scream i'm coming off of a little
splash of cove yeah you sound good
though you know what that kenobi
restored my faith i was a little worried
and you hit that kenomi i said he's back
maybe he's on the upswing next week
it'll be even more screamier uh
for everyone worried in in sending your
concerns and well wishes i appreciate it
so much uh hey we're still living with
this thing called koben right now so
stay safe out there folks we aren't
through with it yet um but i am feeling
better the worst of the symptoms
thankfully are are behind me my fiancee
has been so amazing taking care of me
here in this literal dungeon i am now in
i'm not allowed to leave this room um
for extended periods of time definitely
not going outside to any crowded places
that's for sure and i will be wearing a
mask wherever i go
for quite quite some time anyway
this is wookieleek's it's our weekly
reaction to the latest in star wars i'm
here with tommy bechtold a man with no
hot takes about any slaps in the past 24
hours that's right you will not hear a
hot take about any slaps for me the only
thing i'll say that slaps is that new
calcus lightsaber available at uh star
wars galaxy's hedge and all fine disney
retailers near you i mean everyone wants
us to break down that slap and yes we've
done oscar content here on new rock
stars five or six years ago but what
more am i going to contribute to that
conversation no one no one wants that
from me that's not what i'm made to do i
want i i hope for a day where eric you
and i sit at uh sit on a live stream and
just tear apart people's dresses like
melissa and joan rivers we become the
new fashion police
we're just like
oh man
please that's all i really want that's
everything that we're doing here in the
rock stars is just jews
more like jude crime with that tuxedo
[Laughter]
you see you see what you're missing out
on red carpet this is who you could have
right there please call me back told and
then can i just be the cameraman just
absolutely so i don't have to be on
because i don't have the energy for that
no no no problemo
well tommy tried to make this segue
earlier and i just blew right past it
but in today's episode we're going to
talk about calcus yeah what the
inclusion of the inquisitors really
means for star wars and we're also going
to talk about some late updates about uh
what form darth vader's going to take in
the series before we get to that new
rockstars this week is going to release
our new latest obsession shirt inspired
by the new marvel series moon knight
grabbing one of those it's a great way
to support this channel and all of our
content you can also purchase a custom
shout out that will run during the
inside marvel after shows so head on
over to newrockstarsmerch.com check out
that shirt and all the other great merch
options all right tommy what's our big
question in the world of star wars this
week eric
will calcas disappear in obi-wan kenobi
please say yes please say yes please say
yes
i hope so or at least i hope he gets
referenced at some point cow cast is
just to remind everyone it's the focal
character the 2019 star wars game jedi
fallen order it's a really great game
he's a young jedi survivor of order 66
the character was modeled on the
likeness of and voiced by cameron
monaghan who in recent days actually
made an appearance at disney's galaxy's
edge to introduce the new calculus
legacy lightsaber hilt it has the the
broken end of it which in the game cal
repairs from the broken double-bladed
blue lightsaber of his former master
jaro de paul now in the game at some
point he flashed back to the moments of
order 66 when cal was training under
gyro on the planet baraka on a
venerator-class destroyer
of uh the republic i guess at this point
it's now the empire and the clone
troopers turn on them of course jaro
tries to fight off the troopers and his
lightsaber gets broken in half and cal
ends up getting a blaster uh wound on
his face that's why he has that scar on
his face jaro dies and cal keeps his
saber
but most of the game takes place five
years after this in the year 14 bby
which is when the majority of jedi
fallen order takes place so throughout
the game you face inquisitors you meet
the second sister trilla suduri the
climax of the game actually takes place
in the fortress and courses tourists on
nerd that we now see in obi-wan kenobi
uh here as we saw in the opening cut
scene you face darth vader and cal
escapes with the jedi seer jinda as well
as marin and the captain greece and old
droid bd1 and then he decides to destroy
the jedi holocron to keep the location
of the force sensitive youths secret so
uh the obi-wan kenobi series is actually
going to take place only a few years
after this and it's expected that the
week this series premieres we'll be
getting an announcement about the sequel
for jedi fallen order the next game
so the timing is just so perfect for
cameron monaghan to make a cameo as
calcustus in one of the six episodes of
obi-wan kenobi at least one maybe a few
now we know lucasfilm loves referencing
the game the fortress inquisitor is
coming back another beady droid showed
up in boba fett baraka actually showed
up as a location in bad batch
so what could be the most satisfying way
cal kestis could show up in obi-wan
kenobi could he help but we won't get
out of the jam on daiyu could he be the
one to tell obi-wan about the
inquisitor's fortress on nur how to find
it and would this cameo here set up his
next adventure in jedi fall in order to
and if so what do you think that
adventure would be tommy your thoughts
goodness well i think you know given the
the heavy emphasis on the inquisitors in
the game he he would be a great asset in
an episode to kind of uh you know
debrief obi-wan on what they're doing
you know what i mean like he could kind
of keep kept keep get them get him up to
speed on
on
the dangers and maybe weaknesses he's
discovered and uh
yeah i could see him being kind of like
um
in the way that mandalorian has all
these great side characters that kind of
come in for one episode of season to
like assist and offer their very
specific set of skills uh so i would
like to see that
and in terms of what would uh set up his
next adventure in jedi phone order two
he he destroyed the holocron but i would
like to maybe see him protecting another
young force sensitive uh youth or
something like kind of becoming his
guardian
yeah i mean i think it the way it fallen
order the first one ended was this place
of yeah he's destroying the holocron but
he kind of it's implied that he wants to
use the force alongside cyr yeah to
track down people like that and help
them so it almost sets up this race
against the
inquisitors to find every force
sensitive being out there which to me
like now based off this obi-wan kenobi
trailer it it makes kao kestus
an even more active character at this
point in star wars history than someone
like obi-wan kenobi well we want kenobi
we we know what his goals are but we've
always had this sense in our minds that
he's a pretty uh passive or reactive
character right now he's a bit static
he's just kind of this
guardian who's got a fixed post right um
which is why it's not surprising to see
him leave the planet whereas cal castes
could be at anywhere at any point um
anywhere the inquisitors are calcus
presumably is also trying to get there
so
um yeah my hope is that he
uh that there's their cross paths either
on daiu or some other planet um beyond
diu like if we go to alderaan or
something like that uh or if we're i
don't know if calcus is eager to get
eager to get back to nur
um and to get back to i think if he
if he ever did
he knew he knows that his life would be
over yeah i don't i don't know that yeah
that would be
that would have to be for a very
specific very very specific reason yeah
you know how in in mandalorian season
two um bo katan told um dinjarin where
to find ahsoka tano i think there might
be a similar moment with calcus where he
he tells obi-wan kenobi look if you're
really worried about this you gotta go
over to the fortress inquisitors but let
me tell you as someone who's been there
before it's probably the most dangerous
place a jedi could go yeah oh that would
be perfect yeah if he's like i'll i'll
tell you how to get there but there
ain't no way i'm going with you
yeah yeah and maybe give somebody's like
here's what i remember here's the map
it's kind of like when you play a game
like the visited location shows up on
the map he has literally that printout
like here's where you go and then hit
jump here double jump here use your
lightsaber to twirl up to this platform
great great and then skip past this cut
scene because it's lame um
i don't know what you're talking about
anyway so we also heard some news this
week about uh darth vader um we're going
to get to that in a second but first we
want to thank some people who helped us
make this episode yes well thanks to
babel for sponsoring this episode for
most of us learning a second language in
high school or college wasn't exactly a
high point in our academic careers like
i've retained very little from high
school spanish and what i do remember
ain't that useful but now thanks to
babble there's an addictively fun and
easy way to learn a new language whether
you'll be traveling abroad connecting in
a deeper way with family or you just
have some free time babble teaches bite
size less language lessons that you'll
actually use in the real world several
new rockstar staffers are using babel to
learn new languages around the office so
if you notice our translations and
breakdowns are getting a bit better
you'll know why babel's 15 minute
lessons make it the perfect way to learn
a new language on the go with babel you
can choose from 14 different languages
including spanish french italian and
german plus babel speech recognition
technology helps you improve your
pronunciation and accent it comes with
the 20 day money back guarantee start
your new language learning journey today
with babble right now save up to 60 of
your subscription when you go to
babble.comwookie that's babble.comwookie
for up to 60 off your subscription
babble language for life and uh tommy
has uh some interesting things to tell
us about our other sponsor coinbase
that's right you know eric
cryptocurrency can feel intimidating
you've heard about it you know it's the
big hot thing but you don't know where
to start but let me help you out here
coinbase offers a trusted and easy to
use platform to buy sell and spend
cryptocurrency they support the most
popular digital currencies on the market
and they make them accessible to
everyone even me a man who barely
graduated middle school they offer
portfolio management and protection
learning resources and a mobile app
which i actually have coinbase was the
first digital wallet i ever got in fact
it's the only digital wallet i have and
that is true you can check my phone like
my girlfriend when she thinks i'm
texting someone else so you can trade
securely and monitor your crypto all in
one place millions of people in over 100
countries trust coinbase with their
digital assets whether you're looking to
diversify just getting started or
searching for a better way to access
crypto markets start today with coinbase
for a limited time new users can get 10
in free bitcoin when you sign up today
at coinbase.com slash wookie sign up at
coinbase.com
wookie for ten dollars in free bitcoin
this offer is for a limited time only so
be sure to sign up today that's
coinbase.com
wookie nice now let's get back to uh the
obi-wan kenobi news that we've heard in
the past week deborah chao talked to
entertainment weekly about how they
planned to depict darth vader in the
series 10 years after revenge of the
sith and she said quote for us it's very
similar to obi-wan in the sense that
he's in between these two trilogies so
he isn't the new hope vader quite yet
you know what i mean so
we are with the character sort of in the
middle of this period it is still vader
obviously but it's a vader that isn't
quite as fully formed as a new hope
so my question tommy is what does a not
fully form darth vader look like
well i mean i wonder if that is
referring to his appearance or his
personality right like that's the
question
because the obviously by the time a new
hope starts from watching rogue one
vader is just mercilessly killing the
rebellion like anyone he thinks is like
you know trying to quash the empire he's
he's slashing through with his red
lightsaber he is no longer there's very
little anakin left in him at all so i
think probably what we'll see in kenobi
are the last flickers of anakin
skywalker you know maybe some sense of
grief and pulling him towards the light
side but not that he'll ever go but
maybe some guilt some regret i think all
of those will be tamped up by the end
though you know i think that we're just
going to see like the last embers of
anakin skywalker kind of die
and vader fully take over and you know
become kind of the the weapon evil
terrifying killing machine that he is in
a new hope in rogue one yeah
i think i think you're right tommy um
because i think one of the big um
one of the big confusion points some
people have had here is the line from a
new hope or vader says uh when i left
you i was but the learner now i am the
master um like so what other story could
exist if that's the line he said if he
was referring maybe to the battle on
mustafar he must have been referring to
some other battle um
maybe i think
that deborah charles quote means that
there's still things for for vader to
learn from obi wan right he's like
there's still lessons that the old uh
master still has to impart on the
student which i just love that i love
that they they aren't throwing that line
they aren't retconning that line they're
saying like no there's you're right
there are still flashes of anakin in him
um and if and if you don't buy that if
you think he's all vader at this point
um that there are still
uh there's still things for him to learn
right which is almost kind of terrifying
like yeah i would love to see like some
kind of line between them as they fight
like saying like ah yes this is my final
lesson then or like are you ready for
your final lesson student or something
and then that's when they they fight it
out from that yeah i don't want a fully
formed darth vader yet i know if you're
going to revisit this point in history i
want someone who's still kind of in
transition yeah especially because that
gives hayden christensen more to do
right like that gives yeah for sure if
he's not just doing it you know james
earl jones david prouse infection or uh
impersonation i think you know he can
not that he would impersonate james joel
jones you know what i mean uh if he's
not just embodying that like tone and
cadence and kind of coldness if he's
actually got maybe a little more
emotional you know
uh depth to him now do you think this
could at all uh refer to his appearance
as well so like we we know from the end
of revenge of the sith when the mask
went on he looked pretty much like darth
vader at that point you know or at least
the vader that we know he didn't have
the same kind of like physical presence
that of course he had at the beginning
of a new hope nothing will parallel that
moment but um but i'm saying like once
we see him under the mask we are going
to look like it is going to look like
the scarred face of someone who is still
trying to figure out what their final
form will look like right yeah i guess
yeah we could see the kind of the
transition of you know uh
a a
disfigured hayden christensen that would
be interesting you know like kind of
if if they actually used if they did the
full like prosthetic makeup on him that
would be that would be pretty amazing
actually maybe he hasn't quite
gotten used to that voice
respirator thing and maybe he's still
maybe he's resisting some of the
modifications you know maybe he's trying
to
restore some humanity and he's learning
the hard way that like the only way to
survive
is to have you know be kind of be half
man half machine or mostly machine yeah
i think the the arc for uh the character
might be something like
he begins the series still trying to
cling to what his appearance might be
like you might see either his own face
in his own like mental reflection right
himself that he's trying to cling to
right or him like literally an iron man
close up under the mask or we see him in
his like healing tank or whatever he
hangs out in on mustafar um and that
could be like either scarred hayden
christensen or just like if it's just a
mental projection of him it could just
be his his anakin looking self uh or
maybe he's just going back to flashbacks
of himself during the clone wars era
whatever that manifests as he begins the
series kind of still clinging to that
and getting into those memories uh and
then by the end of the series he
realizes no i'm gonna
let the past die you're gonna let it
burn kill it if you have to kill it if
you have to and he's gonna just cling to
the mask and realize the mask is my
identity now mm-hmm so i'm not i'm gonna
let go of the the flesh identity that i
wanted
just a machine let it go
yeah i'm pretty sure that's the moral of
frozen right yeah at the end of the day
that's what if elsa had turned into
vader or some sort of a sith that would
have been amazing i mean there are
plenty of um grad school analyses of
frozen that make the case that she is
becoming the villain and that's okay
yeah at the end of the day all right i
can do a video essay on that yeah let me
do a video to say right after my minion
breakdown eric
how we all got frozen wrong that's right
here's what you didn't get when you
watched frozen
thawing out all of the things you missed
in frozen
we'll leave it there for this episode of
wookie leaks don't forget to check out
our great merch options over at
newrockstarsmerch.com follow me at ea
boss follow tommy and tommy beck don't
follow new rockstars subscribe to
wikileaks wherever you get your podcast
thank you for watching and goodbye
you